>> YOU CAN EMPLOY SA
ADVANCING IN RUSSIAN OCCUPIED
TERRITORY, PUSHING FURTHER INTO
THE SOUTHERN KHERSON REGION.
THAT AREA IS ONE OF THE FOUR
REASONS REGIONS, RUSSIA HAS
CLAIMED AS THEIR, OWN AFTER
HOLDING SHAM REFERENDUMS.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY TALK WITH SUCCESS OF
WHAT HE CALLS THE FAST AND
POWERFUL ADVANCE.
SO JOINING ME NOW DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN JASON CROW, MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE ARMED SERVICES AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEES.
AND CNN MILITARY ANALYST
COLONEL CEDRIC LEIGHTON.
GOOD EVENING TO BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, COLONEL I'LL
START WITH YOU.
UKRAINE APPEARING TO KEEP UP
ITS MOMENTUM WITH THESE NEW
GAINS, GIVE US THE LAY OF THE
LAND HERE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
UKRAINIAN COUNTER OFFENSIVE?
AND WHY IS IT SO SUCCESSFUL?
>> WELL THIS IS REALLY
INTERESTING, DON, BECAUSE WHAT
YOU SEE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP OF BIG UKRAINE RIGHT HERE,
YOU'VE GOT SOME SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCES THAT THE UKRAINIANS
WERE ABLE TO MAKE IN THE AREA
RIGHT NEAR KHARKIV.
SO EVERYTHING TO THE NORTH AND
EAST OF KHARKIV, IS BEEN PART
OF THE SCENE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
REALLY SO SUCCESSFUL AT.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ADVANCES SPECIFICALLY, YOU SEE
THE FOUR REGIONS, THESE ARE THE
ONES THAT PUTIN HAD SAID HE IS
GOING TO ANNEX --
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LUHANSK,
DONETSK, ZAPORIZHZHIA, AND
KHERSON.
THESE FOUR AREAS RIGHT HERE,
LOOK AT HOW MUCH THE RUSSIANS
ACTUALLY CONTROL.
THEY BASICALLY CONTROL THESE
AREAS RIGHT IN THROUGH HERE.
BUT EVERYTHING YOU SEE IT'S
BEING CONTESTED BY THE
UKRAINIANS.
AND WHAT'S PARTICULARLY
SPECIFIC ABOUT THIS, RIGHT IN
THIS AREA, THEY ARE GETTING ALL
OF THE LOGISTICAL RESUPPLY
AREAS THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE IN
THIS AREA.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
POTENTIALLY, WHAT THEY CAN DO
IS THEY CAN CUT OFF THE
RUSSIANS AND MOVE THEM OUT OF
THIS AREA BACK INTO RUSSIA
ITSELF.
WHICH IS RIGHT HERE.
NOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT INTO THE
HER SONG REGION, IN THE
SOUTHERN PART RIGHT HERE, LOOK
AT WHAT THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
DONE HERE.
THE OBJECT IS TO GET KHERSON,
WHICH IS A UKRAINIAN CITY THAT
THE RUSSIANS OCCUPIED, AT THE
EARLY PARTS OF THIS WAR.
RIGHT, NOW THEY ARE FINALLY
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD, AND
THEY'VE GOTTEN VILLAGES LIKE
THIS ONE, ALEX'S --
--
THESE ARE AN IMPORTANT VILLAGES,
BECAUSE WHAT THEY DO IS THIS
BEGINS THE PROCESS FOR THE
UKRAINIANS TO MOVE IN LIKE
THIS.
AND IF THEY DO, THIS THEY CAN
CUT OFF THE RUSSIAN FORCES THAT
ARE IN KHERSON AND ALSO ON THE
WEST BANK OF THE DNIPRO RIVER.
AND THAT IS A BIG DEAL FOR THEM
AT THIS POINT.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, I'LL BRING
YOU, AND BECAUSE THE U.S. IS
ANNOUNCING TODAY, AN ADDITIONAL
600 AND $25 MILLION IN SECURITY
SYSTEMS TO UKRAINE.
WHAT WE KNOW THE UKRAINIANS
ALSO WANT LONG WAIT ROCKETS
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
DO YOU THINK THE U.S. IS
PROVIDING ENOUGH TO THE
UKRAINIANS?
>> WELL I THINK WE ARE DOING A
REMARKABLE JOB OF SUPPORTING
UKRAINIANS, AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS MOVED
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF EQUIPMENT,
AND WEAPONS, TO THE UKRAINIANS,
AND REALLY, HISTORIC'S SPEED.
BUT THERE IS MORE TO THE STORY
AS WELL.
WE ARE ALSO PROVIDING
INTELLIGENCE SUPPORT, ALSO
PROVIDING TRAINING.
WE ARE PROVIDING STRATEGIC
SUPPORT, PLANNING SUPPORT,
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
WE ARE DOING THAT ARE PUTTING
THE POSITION THAT UKRAINIANS IN
POSITION TO WIN.
IT'S ASTONISHING ACTUALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS AGO, NOBODY
WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE UKRAINIANS
A CHANCE.
BECAUSE ON PAPER, THE RUSSIANS
HAVE EVERY ADVANTAGE.
THE SECOND LARGEST MILITARY IN
THE WORLD, THEY'VE HAD EVERY
ADVANTAGE, JUST FROM AN
ANALYTICAL PERSPECTIVE.
BUT THIS SHOWS THAT PAPER
ARMIES DO NOT FIGHT.
REAL ONES DO!
SO ALL OF THE PROBLEMS THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE ENCOUNTERING, ARE
SHOWING THAT THE DARK
UNDERBELLY OF THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
IT'S ALSO SHOWING THE COURAGE,
THE PROWESS, THE BRAVERY, AND
THE WILL OF THE UKRAINIANS.
>> YOU KNOW, COLONEL, I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THIS NEW A PACKAGE,
IT INCLUDES FOUR MORE HIGH
MOBILITY ARTILLERY ROCKET
SYSTEMS.
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
HOWITZERS.
AND AMMUNITION.
HOW IMPORTANT ARE THESE WEAPONS
TO UKRAINIANS?
>> DON, THERE ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE WEAPONS SYSTEM LIKE THE
HIMARS, FOR EXAMPLE, AND WHAT
WE HAVE HERE A GRAPHIC, TO
SHOW.
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF MODEL
OF HIMARS THAT YOU GET, IT'S
GONNA HAVE A RANGE OF UP TO 300
MILES.
NOW THE UKRAINIANS RIGHT NOW
HAVE A SHORTER RANGE VERSION OF
THIS.
AND IT DOESN'T GO THAT FAR.
BUT THIS IS WHAT IT IS CAPABLE
OF.
IT CAN ALSO, OTHER KEY THING
HERE, AND THIS RELATES TO THE
EIGHTH SACRUM SYSTEM, THAT CAN
BE LAUNCHED FROM A HIMARS
LAUNCHING SYSTEM.
THESE WEAPON SYSTEMS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHAT THEY ENABLE IS THE
TARGETING UP ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE.
SO IF YOU LOOK FOR EXAMPLE, AT
THE MAP RIGHT HERE, AND THE
RANGERS THAT ARE POSSIBLE, IF
YOU HAVE HIMARS LOCATED IN
AREAS LIKE THIS, YOU CAN IN
ESSENCE, GRAB EVERYTHING IN
THESE AREAS RIGHT HERE.
AND IF YOU DO THAT, THIS PUTS
ALL OF THE RUSSIAN FORCES IN
UKRAINE AT RISK.
AND THAT BECOMES A CRITICAL
THING FOR THE UKRAINIANS TO DO,
I ALSO ADVANCES THE GOALS OF
COURSE OF THE WESTERN ALLIANCE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, AS A RUSSIAN
DIPLOMAT WARNING TODAY, U.S.
MILITARY AID, LIKE THE PACKAGE
ANNOUNCED TODAY.
HASTENS A POSSIBILITY OF A
MILITARY CLASH BETWEEN RUSSIA
AND NATO.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THIS
COMPLEX GETTING BIGGER THAN IT
IS?
ESPECIALLY GIVEN PUTIN'S
UNPREDICTABILITY?
>> WELL WE ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
DILIGENT, TO PUTIN'S ERRATIC
TENDENCIES.
HE'S CERTAINLY IS DESPERATE,
NOW HE IS SUFFERING DOMESTIC
POLITICAL PRESSURE.
THE LIKES OF WHICH HE HAS NEVER
ACTUALLY SEEN DURING THIS
TENURE AS PRESIDENT.
SO HE IS STARTING TO DO UNUSUAL
THINGS.
SO THEY HAVE BEEN OR THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN LOOKING
AT ALL THE DIFFERENT SCENARIOS,
LOOKING AT THE DIFFERENT
CONTINGENCIES.
THEY'VE HAD DONE THIS
METHODICALLY, AND DELIBERATELY,
WITH AN EYE TOWARD ESCALATION.
SO WE CANNOT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE CANNOT ALLOW A LOT OF
MY PUTIN TO HAVE VETO POWER
OVER THE WAY THAT WE ARE GOING
TO SUPPORT OUR PARTNERS AND OUR
ALLIES.
WE HAVE TO DO WHAT'S NECESSARY
TO PUT THE UKRAINIANS IN A
POSITION TO WIN.
AND THIS IS THE WAY I'VE ALWAYS
PUT IT --
WE HAVE TO BE WILLING TO DO
WHAT'S NECESSARY THAT INCLUDE
PROVIDING OF THE ATTACK, ENDS
THE PROVIDING OF ADVANCED
FIGHTERS, AND EVERYTHING THAT
UKRAINIANS NEED, TO WIN, THAT
THEY HAVE SHOWN THEIR ABILITY
TO USE.
WE HAVE TO DO WHAT'S NECESSARY
TO PUT THEM IN THE POSITION TO
WIN.
OTHERWISE, WHAT WE ARE DOING IS
WE ARE VOICING A STATUS QUO.
AND THE STATUS QUO WILL OF
VENTRALLY BE WON BY RUSSIA.
UKRAINIANS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS,
THEY CAN WIN THIS, THEY HAVE
THE MOMENTUM.
THEY HAVE THE TACTICAL AND
STRATEGIC CAPABILITY.
NOW IT'S TIME TO FINISH THIS
OFF AND PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
NECESSARY.
>> CONGRESSMAN, I HAVE TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THIS UKRAINIAN POLICE
CLAIMING TODAY TO HAVE
UNCOVERED A TORTURE CHAMBER IN
A TOWN FORMALLY OCCUPIED BY
RUSSIAN FORCES IN EASTERN
UKRAINE.
POLICE SAY AMONG THE ITEMS
FOUND WAS A CONTAINER FULL OF
EXTRACTED GOLD TEETH, LOCAL
RESIDENTS SAY THAT THEY HEARD
SCREAMING, CONSTANTLY, FROM THE
BUILDING.
AS A VETERAN YOURSELF, WHAT DO
YOU THINK WHEN YOU SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
>> WELL, DURING THE INVASION,
IN IRAQ, WHEN I WAS A
PARATROOPER, THEY'VE SAW THESE
STORM OR TROOPERS PARATROOPERS,
ALL THE SIGNS OF THE HISTORY OF
THE TORTURE OF THE SADDAM
HUSSEIN REGIME.
IT'S TERRIBLE, IT'S HORRIFIC,
IT'S THE WORST OF HUMAN NATURE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S
HAPPENING WITH A TERRIBLE
HORRIFIC PREVALENCE BY THE
RUSSIANS IN UKRAINE.
THEY ARE COMMITTING WAR CRIMES.
THEY ARE DOING BRUTAL TERRORIST
THINGS.
THEY ARE USING RAPE AS A WEAPON
OF WAR.
THEY ARE MURDERING INNOCENT
CIVILIANS.
THEY ARE TORTURING AND
EXECUTING PEOPLE, THEY ARE
FOLDING MASS GRAVES.
AND THE ONLY WAY IT'LL STOP --
IF THE UKRAINIANS STOP IT.
WITH OUR SUPPORT!
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
GETTING DONE.
AND THAT'S ALSO WHY, AS A
MEMBER OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, AND LEADING AN
EFFORT, TO CREATE A COORDINATOR,
WITHIN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, TO ACTUALLY GATHER
ALL THE EVIDENCE, ALL OF THESE
WAR CRIMES, SO IT CAN BE
EVENTUAL